In Britain, the House of Commons has rejected for a third time...
...a withdrawal plan backed by Prime Minister Theresa May...
...in a vote on the day Britain originally was scheduled to leave the European Union.
In the US, American and Chinese trade negotiators made progress...
...during "candid and constructive discussions" in Beijing, said the White House,...
...and will continue talks in Washington next week.
In Mozambique, officials in cyclone-stricken Mozambique...
...say the number of cases of cholera has skyrocketed from five to 139.
In Algeria, Algerians take to the streets in Algiers for the sixth Friday in a row...
...to call for an end to the regime of Algerian President Abdelaziz Bouteflika.
Finally from the US, a report in The Wall Street Journal...
...says an anti-stall system was activated on the Ethiopian Airlines Boeing 737 MAX 8...
...before it crashed earlier this month.